so as developers we have a problem we
need to know what the state of our
application is to really understand
what's going on one of the easiest ways
to see that state is something in
JavaScript is to log it to the console
take this basic example we just want to
see what 1 plus 2 is and at the end of
this function let's print the 1 plus 2
variable to the console with the log of
course this is a JavaScript one plus two
is obviously 12 so what do we do now we
go in let's add some more logs one after
every variable assignment one after the
math let's even do the math ourselves in
the log just to see if something changed
between those two lines well that didn't
really help if you look closely you'll
see that it is giving us a bit of a hint
to our answer but I prefer a more direct
approach so let's try to debug our
application just so you know we're gonna
stay in Chrome for this talk but most of
these features are available in Firefox
and Safari as well in the dev tools find
the tab at the top that says sources and
this will be where we're focusing let's
open our JavaScript file from the last
example on the file browser now we are
ready to start debugging with
breakpoints breakpoints are a way to
pause your code in order to start
debugging we're going to quickly go over
a few different ways to do these
breakpoints let's start with the
debugger statement if you flipped at the
bugger's statement in your code when you
have the dev tools open the code is kind
of pause when it gets to that line the
debugger statement does require you to
modify your code just like the console
statements but it is very effective
let's see what it looks like from dev
tools the highlight line is where our
code is currently paused notice it did
the bugger statement there's a lot of
information on the screen though I'm
trying to go over to the important parts
on the right side of the screen you see
the scope variables and what they are
currently set to notice that the two
variable quote is in quotes telling us
that it is a string instead of a number
this is much more helpful than the hint
that the console gave us with the output
being two different colors blue is for
numbers apparently we also get access to
our local scope in the console and we
can run code by typing it in
there's also a call stack which can tell
us where our code was called called from
if you click down the stack you'll jump
to the code that called us instead of
making your code stop every time it hits
the the bugger statement we can replace
it with a manual breakpoint a manual
breakpoint can be added by clicking on
the line number that you want to code
the pause at and once you click you'll
see a blue arrow on the line showing
that a breakpoint has been set at that
line on the right there is a breakpoint
section of dev tools this shows you what
breakpoints exist and you can easily
enable and disable them with the
checkbox next to them once you've run
your code it will stop just like it did
when we had the debug statement in the
good thing about this is that you can
turn the breakpoint on and off as needed
but you can also automatically turn the
breakpoints on and off with a new thing
called conditional breakpoints so for
this example we want to set a breakpoint
after our function has run four times by
right-clicking the number we get more
options for setting the breakpoint
let's choose add a conditional
breakpoint this will bring up an editor
where you can type the breakpoint in the
code about to evaluate when the code is
true the breakpoint will catch and allow
you to start debugging here you can see
it paused on the break point when the my
attempts variable was for sometimes your
code will throw an exception and you'll
want to figure out why this code has an
error that throws an uncaught reference
how do we figure out what the
application state was at the time of
that happened what you want is hidden in
this icon up here that looks like a stop
sign if you hover your mouse the tooltip
says pause on exceptions clicking on it
enables dev tools the breakpoint when an
exception happens let's run our code
again this time you'll see that our
application paused once that exception
happened and we are paused and ready to
debug what the issue might be thank you
[Applause]